just Google it can men menstruate who is
saying this you're doing very small
numbers really hey guys I'm off the grid
for August but we thought you'd enjoy
this old school Reuben report throwback
these are giant left-wing lines we're
talking about degrees to save that men
can menstruate it's a lie and that is
now that is what is said
wait wait wait where did that
okay check it out folks check it out
what not menstruate was considered
transphobic I I miss this whole story
where are you getting just Google it can
then menstrual it but who is saying this
you're always saying very small numbers
then how do you allow men biological men
to run against women in in the races in
Connecticut and set all the high school
records okay they're called men I would
have said they're they're winning okay
but I would agree with you on that the
way you frame it is nonsense no I framed
it perfectly no no no you didn't what
you're talking about is yes someone who
is transgender was a man now claims to
be a woman is a woman okay is beating
the dog out of other women in the
race because of course they have more
muscle mass and even Martina Navratilova
came out and said this is ridiculous you
might not you might as well not have
women's board this is a far cry from
saying men can menstruate I agree but
that's not where anyone went with that
but true okay at the University of
Berkeley Men's Room tampons are given
out
Berkeley Men's Rooms have tampon
dispensers would you would you say
that's probably because men are
whipped and their girlfriend said go get
me a tampon that's why that's a much
more logical okay okay all right moving
on to the next Dennis I remember you in
the old show you were a little more
reasonable
[Applause]
one thing I say that wasn't unreal you
said that we think that men menstruated
no one does have you heard about it I
missed that one I confess and this is
one of the reporters he knows everything
these people are very he's a doctor he's
one of them
that you that the lgbtq normative
statement is men commensurate